écoutez vous tous qui m'attendez à cette
heure
je m'adresse à vous avec toutes
l'émotion que vous pouvez deviner
au vu du résultat tel qu'il nous est
annoncé
au terme de ce premier tour
la nouvelle union populaire
arrivant en tête
elle sera présente dans plus de 500
circonscriptions au deuxième tour
et dès lors
les projections en siège à cette heure
n'ont à peu près aucun sens
sinon celui de maintenir une illusion
puisse-t-elle finir d'étourdir nos
adversaires
pour le reste
la vérité que le parti présidentiel
au terme du premier tour et battu
et défait
pour la première fois de la Cinquième
République
un président nouvellement élu ne
parvient pas à réunir une majorité à
l'élection législative qui suit
notre peuple
au vu de ce résultat
et de l'opportunité
extraordinaire qu'elle présente
pour nos vies personnelles et pour le
destin de la patrie commune
j'appelle notre peuple
à déferler dimanche prochain
bien sûr
pour rejeter définitivement
les projets funestes
de la majorité
de Monsieur Macron
la retraite à 65 ans le travail forcé
pour le RSA et la partie cachée de son
programme qui n'a jamais pu être mis en
débat c'est à dire les 80 milliards
qu'il comptait retirer du budget de
l'État
pour parvenir au retour des 3% de
déficit qu'il avait promis à prudemment
à la Commission européenne
80 milliards c'est à dire retirer du
budget de l'État l'équivalent de tout le
budget du ministère de l'Intérieur et de
tout le budget du ministère de
l'Éducation
et comme nous le savions et comme le bon
sens l'indique il est impossible de
retirer une telle somme d'un budget
c'est non seulement ce projet qu'il
s'agit de rejeter
mais celui qui va avec c'est à dire
l'idée d'une TVA augmenter qui
permettrait de financer
ce projet
alors bien sûr il s'agit de rejeter
d'écarter
mais peut-être plus important et le fait
qu'en déferlant en se mobilisant toutes
et toutes et d'abord dans la jeunesse
à qui le futur appartient et d'abord
dans tous les milieux populaires si
durement éprouvé
par les 30 années de néolibéralisme qui
se sont abattus sur lui
déferler avec vos bulletins de vote pour
ouvrir tout grand la porte du futur pour
lequel ce sont mobilisés tant de
génération avant la nôtre
ce futur d'harmonie entre les êtres
humains débarrassés des dominations
sociales culturelles de genre
un futur d'harmonie entre les êtres
humains et avec la nature
je crois que c'est sans doute
cette page là que vous avez voulu écrire
en votant comme vous l'avez fait vous
autres qui avez placé la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale en tête
mais si vous le décidez alors oui dans
10 jours les prix seront bloqués le SMIC
sera augmenté à 1500 euros
et le lundi des fonctionnaires sera
augmenté
dans un mois vous aurez la retraite à 60
ans en débat
et peut-être avant cela la
titularisation des 800 000 contractuels
de la fonction publique
je ne cite que cela
mais c'est la façon que j'aurais ce soir
de rendre concret
et non politicien
la satisfaction que nous avons en
observant ce résultat qui est le
résultat d'abord d'un accord historique
celui qui a permis la naissance de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale
quand soit remercier tous
sans
exceptions qui ont rendu possible cet
accord
et qui a fini par faire comprendre à
notre peuple que nous étions prêts à
gouverner
avec un programme
et avec une unité qui est démenti à
aucun moment quel qui était les
tentatives faites pour la briser
depuis qu'elle s'est constituée
la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale
affranchi d'une manière magnifique
le premier test qu'elle rencontrait
mener campagne ensemble au coup d'accoud
et convaincre car en démocratie tout se
finit par là il faut convaincre nous
avons beaucoup convaincu
il reste maintenant à faire l'autre
partie du chemin
chacun appréciera dans sa
circonscription quel est son devoir
en républicain en démocrate
et sera quoi faire de son bulletin de
vote
nous n'avons aucun doute sur
l'intelligence de notre peuple
ni aucune réserve à l'égard de la
décision que pour finir il prendra quant
à la composition de l'Assemblée
nationale
c'est pourquoi nous demandons
à ceux avec qui nous nous sommes
affrontés au premier tour de regarder ce
deuxième tour
non seulement sous l'angle des projets
non seulement sous l'angle des
étiquettes
mais sous celui de l'intérêt général de
la patrie et de son peuple
en lançant cet appel déferler décider
par vous-même
je suis certain d'être entendu par des
millions de gens qui jusque là peut-être
n'avaient même pas imaginé que deuxième
tour ils auraient t'apprendre une
décision comme celle qui se présente à
eux dans 500 circonscriptions
la nouvelle union populaire écologique
et sociale
et fier d'avoir rendu possible
son programme
elle est fière de l'oeuvre accomplie
elle regarde le peuple français
avec la tranquillité du travail accompli
et d'une perspective radieuse qui se
présente à lui
vive la République vive la France
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]